[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another episode
of Fandango in the movie guide today I
have a bunch of selections for you to
watch in theaters and at home so let's
get into it with a film that's
unfortunately very very timely it's
called An Inconvenient sequel truth to
power the most criticized scene in the
movie An Inconvenient Truth was showing
that the combination of sea level rise
and storm surge would flood the 9/11
memorial site and people said what a
terrible exaggeration Hurricane sandy
slammed into New York City last night
plotting the World Trade Center site
this sequel comes 10 years after Al
Gore's film An Inconvenient Truth which
blew a lot of people's minds wide open
about the issue of climate change once
again
Al Gore takes you through how the earth
is slowly heating up how things are
becoming catastrophic in terms of
weather patterns and what people can do
about it when I saw this film at
Sundance Al Gore spoke about wanting to
have further conversations with
President Trump since then of course
Trump has talked about getting the u.s.
out of the Paris agreement virtually
every nation in the entire world agreed
to get to zero greenhouse emissions it
is unprecedented it reminds you of how
much optimism people like Al Gore and
scientists and people working in the
field really do have that we can turn
this around whatever your politics are I
urge you to go and see an inconvenient
sequel truth to power this is our home
a much lighter film which I've also got
to see at Sundance is called Briggs
b-bear this is a comedy starring Kyle
Mooney
what's on your mind now it's just there
are other people out there just like us
right
and we're all watching groups be
together kyle mooney plays a young guy
who right at the beginning of the film
is rescued from an underground bunker
he's been living there his entire life
he was kidnapped when he was young and
the people he thought were his parents
were actually not plus he soon realizes
that a show that he was obsessed with
called Briggs bbear was actually not a
real show no matter how old you are that
is a lot to deal with and so this is
kind of a coming-of-age story at a much
later age
did they ever touch you did grab me and
they'd say great job on your studies
James it is so funny and the thing I
love is Kyle Muniz character in what
Kyle brings to the role is very innocent
and beautiful he is such a likable
character that you just want him to
succeed and he realizes that the way
that he needs to navigate this new weld
is through the character of Briggs
b-bear Briggs me never gives up and I'm
not giving up either and I've actually
come up with some new ideas that I
really want to tell you guys about but I
I'm not let's just say let's just say
that I'm onto something pretty big this
movie is genuinely sweet in just a very
nice uncynical way be normal hi I'm
James I really like your clothes
Briggs be fair is out in limited
theaters from this weekend your right
friend
the act of the light world of comedy now
the incredible Jessica James is out on
Netflix from this weekend and this is
another bright spark of Sundance this is
a romantic comedy directed by Jim
Strauss who had a movie in 2015 called
people places and things which had a
small role for Jessica Williams now he's
written an entire film for her and this
is an incredible star making role she
has so much charisma it bounces off the
screen and her character is definitely
flawed but intensely likeable I don't
wanna be here right now
oh well why would I be offended by that
I thought this would be good for me to
help me get over this guy I thought it
was a moment but this whole thing is
making me think of him more intensely
cool the incredible Jessica James
touches on dating it touches on to fall
as it touches on what does success look
like but all tied up in a very funny
very light-hearted bow I'm 25 I'm sort
of in this weird transitional phase
Damon I need to tell you how I feel fine
how do you feel I don't know you'll walk
out of this and you'll think yes that
girl just has it and that's why
reviewers we're glowing about her and
this film at Sundance it's never too
soon to start questioning the system
what system the system map to I'm not
pretty system you just pretended to eat
poop out of a diaper so now you get to
experience it for yourself the
incredible Jessica James from July 28
that's this Friday very complicated
person I know I'm sorry you never need
to apologize for that
there's so many other things that
apologize there you have it if you're
not gonna go see Charlie's sorrow and
kick butt in atomic blonde or you're not
interested in emojis being turned into a
movie here are some great
recommendations and inconvenient sequel
Grigsby Beth incredible Jessica James
I'm Alicia Malone let me know in the
comments below or on Twitter at Alicia
Malone which movies you want to see and
why I always always love to hear from
you guys and I will see you next week
with many many more little indie gems
for you to enjoy
[Music]